hi it's our lady jay and i'm here with
karen delepina collison to talk about
her nickel winning script coming of age
which is set in 1965 britain where a 14
year old sheltered schoolgirl is
catapulted into the tumultuous backstage
world of the bedroom fast tour her
mother stage manages where she
experiences a scandalous sexual
awakening
[Music]
hello
hello
i really enjoyed reading your script you
read it
i did of course thoroughly entertained
and went on a lovely journey what is the
most
challenging
part of writing for you when i get a
note i love getting notes i i did
journalism in one of my my incarnations
and i just thought oh this is fantastic
people are saying edit that out and i go
why and then i realize oh that's so much
better so i've always loved that i'm
glad that you said you love getting
notes like it's one of my favorite
things as well as long as i have a
relationship of trust with the person
who's giving the note sometimes
you do have to push back on a note if
your experience is very specific i've
discovered that
that my truth is more my boss than
anybody else beautifully said it's also
easier if you present options with
saying no i found you know getting a
round of notes and going through them
all and one standing out is like i don't
think that works but here's something
else how what about this scene
so i have uh heard a lot about the
specter of of the pitching it's really
just another way of performing
um as an actor i'm sure you will know
you'll be familiar and comfortable with
pitching once you get the first few out
of the way at first it's very
nerve-wracking
can i ask you about like a eureka moment
that you found while working on the
script that allowed you to break a story
i don't think i had any big
aha that you know except in terms of oh
i see how i can solve that oh i see no
way i can go there i think one of the
reasons maybe there wasn't a real eureka
moment in the script of yours is that
the characters are developed
so well
often
when you spend time on characters and
really give them life
and understand their backstory and the
choices that they would make
those choices become very easy and very
clear when you set them all in a room if
you have you know four characters you've
developed and then you bring them all in
a room together
you're just gonna watch them talk to
each other and then you're gonna
translate whatever they're saying
true
what went into creating these characters
he said part of it was based on
folks that you knew i started in the
family environment of my childhood which
was not an easy childhood but when i
started to write i discovered how much
joy
there was there and certainly that
wasn't anything that i expected
horowitz
the classical pianist once said that
pianists shouldn't practice more than
two or three hours a day because it's
living that creates the artist and it
sounds like you've done a lot of living
in order to bring those characters alive
and it really reads and it's really
beautiful thank you i really
enjoyed every moment of reading it and
chatting with you as well i have no
doubt that you will be very successful
and i look forward to everything that's
to come thank you so much thank you
she was as lovely as i expected her to
be i'd love to be in her presence more
and maybe maybe life will present that
opportunity we'll see
you